here's a question I've been sent in by a
viewer which is to prove the inequality
5 to the N plus 9 is less than 6 to the
N and proven by mathematical induction
now probably the reason why people have
difficulty with it is that when you have
a look at it this 5 to the N and this 6
to the end they present some issues with
us because if you would say 5 times n
and six times n it'll be easy to
simplify these two they'll be able to
interact with each other quite easily
but because the N is up in the index
this 5 ms6 because they're different
bases they don't play nicely together
we've got to be a little more tricky
with how we prove it okay so crowd is a
mathematical induction begin first you
have to test for the first allowable
value and make sure the inequality
actually does work now one of the
interesting things I haven't given a
domain with this question
you know what values of n we have to
prove four but if you just have a think
you know it doesn't work for all of them
for instance n to power if M is zero
right what it'd be here on the left hand
side will it be 5 to the power 0 which
is 1
so B 1 plus 9 so the left hand side be
10 and the right hand side would be 6 to
the power 0 which is 110 less than 1
well that's not true and even if you put
in the next value so if you start at the
positive integers if animal 1 you'd get
5 here and 6 here so your left hand
that's gonna be 14 your right hand side
is gonna be 6 well 14 isn't less than 6
either okay
so I'm assuming that for this question
the domain we've been given is an is
going to be greater than or equal to 2
as you'll see in a second to does work
okay so let's give this a spin shall we
I'm gonna test for and equals to my left
hand side what's it going to be equal to
5 squared plus 9 that's 25 plus 9 which
is 30 for the right hand side is 6
squared so that's 36 so sure enough left
hand side is left then the right hand
side in this case okay
therefore the inequality holds it's true
for and equals to 2 which is what we're
thinking is our first allowable value
okay so what's the next step in a
mathematical induction proof it's the UM
it's the important step for a
by mathematical induction it's the
inductive hypothesis or the assumption
okay
namely that the statement is true for
some arbitrary value of n that fits the
rules that we know so far so we'll call
that value K and we're proving this for
K being a an integer but not just any
integer it has to be greater than or
equal to two just like n does okay right
now what does it look like this name it
look like we'll simply do the
substitution stick in case wherever you
see ends and this is what we're assuming
to be true okay so the third step is now
on on this assumption I want to prove
that the statement is true for the next
value along this is where our work is
going to begin so I'm going to I want to
prove that it's true for N equals K plus
1 okay now what does that look like I
need to prove that if I put in K plus 1
instead of K I'll have this 9 and that's
gonna be a k plus 1 over there as well
okay so now this is actually what I'm
after and this is where all of our
algebra is going to come in this is what
I want to prove okay now with inequality
proof often the easiest place to start
is actually with the assumption okay and
we're going to try and take this and
twist and turn it so that we can turn it
into something like this or something
equivalent to it okay and that
equivalence by the way is going to be
crucial later on so let's start with
this line the Assumption by assumption 5
to the k plus 9 is less than 6 to the K
all right now what can I do with this in
order to make it look like or look as
close as possible to what I'm trying to
prove okay well looks to me like the the
simplest difference is that on the right
hand side what's the difference I've got
a 6 to the k plus 1 here that's what I'm
trying to get to here I've 6 to the K
right well the difference is just a
factor of six right and to see that
you've just got to remember your index
laws that six to the k plus one is
really a way of writing six to the code
multiplied by 6 to the 1 which of course
is just 6 okay so for me thinking about
I mean there's many ways to do this but
the quickest way to start making what
this looks like what I'm required to
prove is just to multiply everything
through by 6
okay so let's give that a go I've got a
6 over here multiply everything and then
I'll put a 6 over here ok now what do we
got now the right hand side if I
simplify that a little more that looks
exactly like what we want okay so that's
a very promising okay what do I have on
the left hand side well remember what
I'm trying to get is a 5 to the k plus 1
5 to the k plus 1 now in just the same
way that I saw that 6 to the k plus 1 is
6 to the K times 6 this is 5 to the K
times 5 right to the power of 1 so how
can I get that out of what I've got here
I'm not multiplying by 5 any entries I'm
multiplying by something better than
five I'm multiplying my six right so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna rewrite
that six as a five plus one now why am I
gonna rewrite it as five plus one
because I want to multiply that 5 to the
k plus 1 right so a 5 to the k plus 1
outside of 5 to the k plus No okay now
when I expand this left hand side and
now I'm just looking exclusively at the
left hand side because the right hand
side exec is exactly how I want it right
what am I going to have let's do the 5
first so I've got 5 times 5 to the K and
then 5 times 9 is 45 right then I've got
1 lot of 5 to the K and I've got a knife
okay that's less than or equal to 3
listen sorry seeks to the k plus 1 okay
now ordinarily I'd put this 45 in this
nine together but for now I'm gonna
leave them and you'll see why later
I don't need to simplify them together
now this 5 times 5 to the K there is the
5 to the k plus 1 that I was after right
I'm gonna swap these two numbers around
because if you can see I want the five x
to the K to the power of K plus 1 and
the 9 to be together because in my what
I'm required to prove that's what I've
got right so I'm gonna have 5 to the k
plus 1 plus 9 and then I have these
other two terms these extra terms right
so just to show that they're a bit extra
I'm gonna put them in brackets you okay
seeks to the k plus 1 right now let's
think about this you here's where the
thought is required and where this is
not the same as say solving an equation
or proving an equation to be true right
the difference is that what I have here
is not exactly the same as well I'm
gonna try to prove okay I was you might
be expecting to get that exactly on the
left-hand side but I don't have that
exactly I've got this plus other stuff
okay
but can you see that that's actually not
a problem for us right because what I've
proved is that this right-hand side 6 to
the k plus 1 is this is greater than if
you're thinking about it you know I'm
going from this side to that side this
number is bigger than these two numbers
together right this number and this
number okay added together and remember
that 5 to the K is positive right so
none of these numbers are actually
negative yeah so I can say since she's
the K plus 1 this side is greater than
this side all of it I can say that it's
greater than just a part of it right I
can say that it's greater than just that
on its own without this extra bit since
5 to the k plus 45 that must be positive
right because K must be positive so just
in case you you missed what that step is
about right it's a little bit like this
suppose we were trying to prove that um
5 3 is less than 5 okay and what we
eventually got to write was that 4 is
less than 5 we can if we can prove that
well that's 3 plus 1 is less than 5 and
that's not the same as what we're trying
to prove but it's better right because
one's positive so if
rebus one is less than five then surely
3 is less than 5 so that's what I've
done here I've eliminated this part I
can I can just we're not really
eliminate it I just disregard it because
it doesn't change the direction of the
inequality in fact it just makes it more
obvious that this numbers bigger than
this number which is even bigger than
this number right so this is what I was
setting out to prove this implies or
this means that the statement is true
for n equal K plus 1 okay so what have I
done I tested for the first value which
was two right that's what we did up here
and I showed that it was actually the
case then I said well let's just assume
this is true I don't know if it is okay
but we just assumed it but on the basis
of that assumption we proved this
statement okay now here's the thing
since I've proved it for to write this
statement would be true if I put twos in
there but this statement is true if this
one is true and so if this is true for
two it to be true for three if it's true
for three it's proof true for four and
so on right so therefore and different
different places different schools
universities will word their conclusion
a little bit differently but you know
you might just say by the principle of
mathematical induction
the statement is true for your first
value right which we said was - and
every subsequent one right which is all
we needed to prove that's it that's the
proof